busted murderers we've taken down
cartels but today we face the worst New
York has to offer the fire department
Fire Marshal Boone we meet again
detective Peralta your fly's down and
made you look
I didn't look and I'm wearing shorts
there is no fly that's how what your mom
said you make no sense and now I'm
inside your head prepare to die
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Lizzie Lizzie welcome welcome welcome I
have a lot of bottles there
oh yeah would you like a vitamin b12
evening primrose oil willow bark
magnesium no thank you
sure you're the good for hangovers okay
I'll take one I take care of my body
above all else
diet exercise supplements positive
thinking scientists believe that the
first human being who will live 150
years has already been born I believe I
am that human being
Terri just pulled two doubles you must
be tired I'll stay for this Whitman
debacle you go home I'm not tired
why would you think I was tired I ended
up doing 25 minutes of sleep chin-ups on
muscle memory alone tired Terri still
gets after that's all I'm saying hey Ann
what happened I just saw you a few hours
ago and you were fine
not like damn you're fine but fine
health-wise my body has no fat to
protect itself from disease things
happen very quickly listen to me it's
very important that you replenish my
body with electrolytes after every
involuntary loss of bodily fluids
my body since losing a lot of fluids
when it's sick my brain is on fire
I'm dying mm-hmm well you definitely
have the flu oh my god the microchip has
been compromised
hello Terry I just thought I'd stop by
and let you know that I'm on my way to
the bank
that's right I'm gonna pay you back
because I know your secret what are you
talking about I don't have a secret oh
really
fact the first after years of not caring
about my debt you weirdly want me to pay
you back now that implies to me that
there is a sudden unexpected expense or
I got sick of waiting for you to do the
right thing not plausible you have
endless patience for my shenanigans in
fact the second you've had dentist
appointments twice in the past two weeks
no one goes to the dentist that much I
haven't been in seven years you should
go to the dentist Jake gravely I
teeth hurt all the time fact the third
I'm really liking this fact the thing
I'm gonna stick with it fact the fourth
I found this on your desk it's a list of
names Nathaniel Jeffords Alexa Jeffords
those are my cousin's name lies there's
but one conclusion you Terry Jeffords
are pregnant the names are baby names
the dentist and obstetrician and the
money is for baby things like diapers
does anybody else know no just you and
your wife and crash that's what I think
you should name the baby works for a boy
or a girl listen up Jake we just found
out Sharon is pregnant and it's way too
early to tell anyone this is a secret do
you understand me do you do you
understand me physical very quickly this
is a don't stop Jake serious look I
promise I won't tell anyone all right my
lips are sealed
good do I even weigh anything you know
April you are very intelligent and savvy
young woman I do not think of you as
just a gofer but right now I need you to
get me a triple espresso with eight
sugars okay what I'm on it I'll go I'm
going please I can go I don't mind it's
better than listening to a stump speech
for a millionth time no I will do it I
have to do it I need to do it goodbye
this has been a difficult year for me
romantically Millicent gergich in
Perkins Andy's professor that's a
disappointment but if I keep my body
moving and my mind occupied at all times
I will avoid falling into a bottomless
pit of despair Sarge it's so good to see
you I just out of curiosity how did you
find out about this I'm a detective
sergeant in the NYPD hold Toby why are
you cutting me out of operation what
that's crazy
Boyle come in here and stand in front of
my body and tell them that's crazy
go talk to me now uh
if you could be any vacation oh you let
me finish
if you could be any vacation what would
you be I'd be skiing oh no I'm gonna hit
you for real that wasn't for real oh my
god don't worry worried about what about
you getting hurt
I don't want your daughters growing up
without a dad I know what that's like
and it sucks and I don't want it to
happen to them why did you say something
to me because I didn't want to get in
your head and have you freak out again
oh I get it
it's been a rough year but I've learned
to embrace my fears it makes me a better
cop tax 1 & 2 are set 30 minutes until
the bogeys arrive
thanks Boyle I love it when you say
bogeys so we good we good for the record
if I could be any kind of vacation I'd
be Lake trip classic I vomited somewhere
in this room I don't remember where
though wait you might want to check that
drawer stop pooping it's not the turnout
I was hoping for maybe I should have
offered free strudel then at least
Scully would have come yes free strudel
what a hell did you go from I don't get
it
I am shocked that more people wouldn't
want the tutelage of our precincts nay
our city's most esteemed sergeant what
do you want Santiago to learn the
majestic art of self-defense from our
cities may our country a little man out
with it I don't want to start class
okay I'm applying for a mentorship
program for up-and-coming detectives
it's called star achieving mentor star
achieving mentees or Sam Sam for short
would you write me a recommendation of
course I will
you'd be great Thank You Sarge all right
everyone pay attention Santiago I'm
gonna come at you and you're gonna take
me down you better impress me if you
want that recommendation to be good I'm
gonna try Sarge
and that's what you get for lying about
free strudel
Karma's a [ __ ] and Birkins hey Chris
gotta run to a meeting with Ron great
idea I'll run to my next meeting
damn it Boyle you left the fridge open
the door couldn't shut because of your
empty pizza box
it's heats up please this is a butternut
squash and truffle butter flatbread
everything spoiled my lunch is ruined
chicken potatoes pasta meatballs
Pam yogurt yogurt I love yogurt so this
is your lunch for like the mud I need to
eat 10,000 calories a day to maintain
muscle mass my wife made me all of this
before she left town with the kids that
was everything in my fridge Scully
hey Sarge I know you got a secret stash
food hidden somewhere oh no where is it
no I don't is it air pocket come on I'm
gonna shake it out of your pockets
turn around Sarge lips golly oh this is
fun wait you wanted to see me good god
what the hell are you doing upside-down
situps great exercise and it literally
lets me see the world from a different
perspective
isn't there a men's gymnasium where you
could do that the world's my gymnasium
Rob hey Terry you get my email about how
I was coming down here no I haven't
checked my phone no need I just wanted
to make sure you're here you know you
know how I like to have a wait mate
really I have never seen you in the gym
what I basically live here I'm a regular
Jim Dandy besides I got to get into
shape for all the Godfather I'm gonna do
I mean how am I gonna throw our baby up
into the air with these noodle arms good
point so take me through your workout
man rip me up you know let's rip it out
time to rip it down those aren't gym
times and I don't think you could handle
my workout
Wow sounds like a challenge to me come
on you have to come up with some
solution for this mud problem some of
his a slug infestation
boy oh boy we live interesting lives
dobe with unexpected challenges life is
precious and every day is a miracle okay
freak what is happening just a tummy
gurgle damn messed up my sister Oh No
[Music]
you